we have such a great show tonight I
could hang you thank you I am your
biggest fan it's my pleasure who's next
hello oh hey there look it's Chris
Parnell look at that
welcome to comic-con oh thank you very
much yeah
Chris what are you what are you doing
here I'm assigning my new novel here you
go thank you your new novel yes that's
right after five long years love hammer
is finally out my fans have been very
patient Donen crystal can be wrong it's
great that you wrote a novel it really
is gonna have actually written six
novels so fine great that you've written
six novels why are you in my theater oh
well this was the cheapest booth at
comic-con
Comic Con Comic Con is almost a mile
away from here yeah which is why this
booth was so cheap yeah okay
Conan gonna do you mind I've got a lot
of sex storm fans here who won't sign
copies of love hammer I'm sorry
sex storm yeah yeah look love hammer is
just the most recent entry and my sex
storm series of erotic fantasy novels
they follow the adventures of Horatio
winter a brave knight whose magical
penis or love hammer is the only thing
just do me a favor and stop saying love
hammer okay whose magical penis is the
only thing that can save the kingdom
from other evil magical penises I'm
surprised you've never heard of Horatio
winter in his sexual adventures yeah no
I have never heard of any of these books
or the popular catchphrase from my
novels okay I'll bite what's that winter
is coming
laughs I think you should leave you
should leave Chris no wait not until he
signs my copy all right Chris Parnell
everybody hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography